nostalgia critic guy remember it so you
don't have to if there's anything Avatar
The Last Airbender has taught us is that
there's a yin to every yang for every
good there is a bad and it's our duty to
acknowledge them in order to keep
balance
considering how avatars my favorite show
of all time it only makes sense in other
of this philosophy to go over what many
you would probably see as a
controversial issue that of course being
the bed episodes of avatar for no
particular reason I will now talk let me
go into a little bit more detail in my
opinion there's really no such thing as
a bad episode of avatar even the weakest
episodes have something of value in word
that goes beyond what's presented in
most family-friendly shows but if we
want to acknowledge the best it also
made sense to acknowledge the words so
we can figure out how to continually
make the art grow stronger so I see no
fault in looking over the not bad but
just not as good at the so - one of the
greatest TV shows of all time uh critic
are you sure that's wise look we're all
adults and we're going to talk about
this in an adult wait so what's the
problem just that when people see the
word worst in the title they might think
the wrong thing well that's technically
what it is isn't it the worst are the
best I'm not afraid of a bunch of
fanboys and fangirls especially for a
franchise I love so much okay Shane your
life had to end this way I'll be fine
thanks
so without further ado do you mind I can
hear you're all the way in here that's
an even bigger shame jaw like I was
saying we're gonna look at the top
eleven yeah it is good episodes up an
all-around great series why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back and enjoy the top 11
technically worst episodes of Avatar The
Last Airbender
boiling rock part 1 in this episode Zuka
and sokka try to break out the prisoners
from their failed invasion by getting
capture themselves and working with
Sookie to find a way out in all fairness
very little is wrong with the premise
the development even the kick-ass action
scenes that come from it the problem is
minor but still a noticeable one that
being why is there a part one at all
seriously this could have been just one
episode in fact if it was it could have
possibly been the most tightly written
action-packed one there ever was but
instead we get time dedicated to
planning an escape from the prison
putting that plan to motion and
ultimately having a fail which of course
leads to the second planning of an
escape from the prison and a second
attempt to put it into motion that one
succeeds but well why the hell did they
just edit the first one out then were
they just short an episode so they
decided to stretch one out a little more
don't get me wrong there's a lot of
character there's a lot development it
furthers the story but I think all that
probably could have been fit into one
episode maybe with just a tiny cut here
there I guess in some respects it's a
bit more realistic not to have the first
attempt succeed but it's also realistic
that Appa would most likely eat Momo at
some point but that doesn't mean to want
to see it when the episode finally does
get going with the real plan in part two
it's great it's a lot of fun it's just
seeing through part one that isn't bad
but it isn't necessary either probably a
nitpick but like I said this is the
worst of the best so you'll probably see
a couple more you happy now I'm never
happy number 10
the Serpent's pass team avatar has to
pass through a dangerous route to get to
the city of Ba Sing se after agreeing to
take a pregnant couple with them and
being reunited with Sookie the team
tried their best not to get gobbled up
by a giant beast while also working out
their emotional problems again not a bad
premise but the emotional problems
they're working through just artists
engaging compared to other episodes for
example Sokka gets overprotective Sookie
because he has lost a loved one before
but we know how it's gonna end right
he's is up as she convinces him that she
can take care of herself just by getting
captured later but come on that's like
setting a bowling pins egg is still
dealing with the loss of Appa but we've
got a lot of that a much more intense
episode prior so again it just kind of
feels like leftovers heck even Zuko's
problem seems pretty mundane just trying
to get more food with jets gang and a
ferry um on earth not that these are bad
problems to focus on but when you
combine them all together and also throw
in a mother giving birth just kind of a
slow one even the serpent compared to
all the other great designs they've had
on the show is not especially that
memorable I mean what was the
combination of animals on that one the
dragon from zelda 2 with a novelty map i
know means awful but even as the slower
episodes go this one just felt really
stuck I guess if that was the intention
of the episode it definitely worked
nothing major not
jet fresh off the last episode jet has a
great morale with a great payoff but
kind of the less than thrilling
character to do it with jet on the
surface seems interesting enough he's
like a young Robin Hood trying to teach
the Fire Nation a lesson but goes too
far when he tries to take out innocent
civilians this creates some interesting
baggage for the character but for the
most part he's just kind of a
good-looking thief he's there to throw
another wrench into Aang and Katara's
romance and mostly just be a good look
Boyle is nothing he has no character
it's just not very much again by avatar
standards it's not that he's annoying or
unpleasant it's just we've seen the
good-looking hero who it turns out is
not the hero and has a stubborn side
that's just never going to change most
of us know it's coming and we're just
kind of waiting for it to take its
course while the more Allah teaches
about innocence caught in the crossfire
of war is certainly a strong one I do
wish there was a slightly better
character to get across with if he was
even more memorable maybe this could
have been an even bigger deal the kid
equivalent of Magneto or something as is
he's not bad but like the episode proved
he's certainly not everything he was
built up to be doesn't seem fair does it
number
cave of two lovers the romance on avatar
has always been one of the weaker points
and Lee's praying in guitar anyway it's
not that I can't see them together it's
that we have to go through a lot of the
same cliches we've gotten in other
romances where they'll always be overly
awkward which leads to a
misunderstanding which leads to them
being angry at each other and of course
leads to them both realizing they were
wrong
say directed by Gary Marshall and we got
a wrap in this episode we go through
most of that in a setting called the
cave of two lovers on the one hand I'm
kind of glad all the romantic comedy
cliches were kind of gotten out in this
one episode but still I don't think you
needed them to begin with falling in
love is interesting enough without
having to feel you always have to throw
in this constant bickering this
continuing formula of the couple that
argues all the time but that somehow
gets together in the end I mean why does
there have to be so much bickering in so
many romances don't they know that's
what marriage is for you know they're
going to get together so I never got why
they tried to drag it out as long as
they did they can get together early on
there's nothing wrong with it have them
be a couple afterwards work through a
relationship stuff that would happen
after you decide to be a couple come on
there's other areas to go in this and
granted it's not office bad but it has
those romantic comedy trademarks that
avatar just seems to be above but still
when a nice scene does play out it does
seem legitimately nice and we do see
Sokka deal with this world's
interpretation of well hippies so is by
no means a loss but I think this couple
can definitely be strong enough without
the Julia Roberts tropes and God help
you if you actually make guitar laughs
that way number seven
the waterbending master after making
their way to the Northern Water Tribe
guitar is horrified to discover that
they don't teach women and girls how to
fight but only how to heal so she faces
off with the prejudice of Aang's new
master to show sisters are doing it for
themselves I never know how to feel
about episodes like this on the one hand
yeah there's always going to be people
or cultures we're gonna be prejudiced
about anything
gender Ray's appearance whatever so it
makes sense to stand up against that on
the other hand isn't the message done
better if instead of preaching about
what you want to see you just show it
growing up as a little boy I always
loved Gosselin from darkwing duck and
Babs from Tiny Toons I didn't care that
they were girls and that's because the
show didn't care either
they were just funny characters that
were part of the group so I never had
any problem with them however when the
troupe of girls proving they can do what
boys can do comes in always feel like
it's making the character more statistic
than a person and guitar is definitely
not that neither her gender nor any
prejudice against her was her identity
so this plotline didn't seem especially
needed as a kid if the people in the
world you love accept something it's
more likely you're gonna accept it too
but again on the other hand we do know
all this bullshit does happen in the
world and there's always going to be
idiot douchebags out there who enforce
it so it's probably good to be prepared
for it right it's hard to say what the
best route to take is but with this
episode we all know exactly what that
route is going to be she's going to win
him over and of course he's going to
teach her in the end even if you are
gonna take this road isn't there a
slightly different way you could do it
some variations something we didn't see
coming no we did get some great water
bending action great shots of the city
and hey it's still these great
characters being great characters
I guess all I'm looking for is a little
bit more variety in the message or at
least the teaching of the message but
again I still got to see Katara do what
Katara does and is pretty awesome so I
can't complain too hard you can
knock me down number six
sokka's master this actually ties into
the same argument I had with the last
one only this time it's a bit of a
different prejudice Sokka feels bad
because he's not a bender like Anka taro
or Toth because of this he feels totally
useless so he finds a master to teach
him the art of sword fighting and being
a great fighter he even manages to put a
sword made from a meteorite together so
now he never has to feel left out ever
again the strange thing about this
episode is that through the previous
seasons they've tried to convince us
Sokka had a point and in my opinion they
succeeded Sokka was more than just the
comic relief he was the idea guy the one
who thought out of the box the one who
at times could be a little too nutty but
always came through with what he needed
to come through with he even already had
a weapon his trusty boomerang and we all
associated it with him so the idea of
acting like he had no pardon everything
I was going on didn't seem necessary he
was important not just for last before
strategic planning and he was good at it
right even so this whole episode about
him trying to feel redeemed and valuable
didn't really pay off because we already
thought he was again it's drawing
attention to a prejudice you probably
weren't prejudiced against and possibly
didn't even know was a thing
sokka's fine no improvements needed it's
almost like the creator's were
anticipating a backlash for him that as
far as I know never came who can't love
Sokka suckas great never change for
anyone big guy keep it real Water Tribe
number five the swamp a lot of things
are hinted at in this episode but many
of them don't turn out coming very far
the team is lost in a swamp that gives
visions of the past present and even
future while trying to figure out what
it means they're also trying to outrun a
couple of swamp rats who want to eat
their animal companions for dinner the
ending is definitely interesting as it
delivers a message about how all things
are connected and to its credit in a
very creative way but there's one major
problem you're in the swamp a disgusting
dark bug filled gloomy ass swamp who the
hell wants to be in a swamp
there isn't any fun goodness being like
a nice forest or a creepy forest or an I
don't know which is anything but a swamp
do we really have to focus on this
world's version of duck dynasty I think
we can survive without that we also get
the return of Zuko as the Blue Spirit as
well as haunting memories from katara
and sokka's past but none of them seemed
to especially go far in the long run the
only thing that really plays a big part
is Aang seeing a vision of Toph who
would eventually become his earthbending
teacher but aside from that rich is
stuck in this nasty-ass swamp and don't
get me wrong I know a lot of his don't
judge a book by it's cover and honestly
they did get a lot more wisdom
entertainment than I would have thought
they would have in this environment but
yeah the avatar version of deliverance
not a fan
The Painted Lady I think we all kind of
cringe when we hear an episode of
anything is going to be about the
environment and yes the environment is
important save the earth all that good
stuff but let's face it guys it's so
rarely done well truth be told there's
only two family related shows I can
think of that handle it with any
subtlety or intelligence Sonic the
Hedgehog a knife in choking there
actually is a subtle environment message
in there much better than that's our
show
and of course avatar the whole show
definitely has a strong tie to nature
health the nations are named after the
four elements but it was never rubbed to
much in your face that is with the
exception of this well no way is bad as
other environmental messages why did the
show feel they needed one addressing
pollution and saving the earth the
show's already kind of been doing that
with its subtlety hasn't it Katara is
concerned because while they're not
supposed to interfere with the Fire
Nation yet a village is starving and
losing their home to pollution so she
disguises herself as the spirit of the
river known as The Painted Lady to feed
and heal all those who need it it brings
up a good debate on how far does one go
before interfering with other cultures
but like many of you when you see a big
bad factory spewing sludge and young
kids who control the elements try to
help I only think of one thing again as
most environmental episodes of FAMILY
shows go this one is not honestly that
bad but compared to what the rest of the
show had been naturally giving us all
this time this one's just a hint too
obvious you wouldn't mind keeping that a
secret by the way would you no problem
number three
the headband now I'm just gonna say it
avatar really really of all the movies
for avatar - joyfully rip-off we get a
bizarre version of Footloose yeah what
loose hanging the gang had to sneak
through the fire nation dressed as
civilians but Aang gets picked up by a
school and sure enough he's now getting
an education the only downside is the
kids aren't allowed to have fun what to
do
blow a party inviting all the kids and
show them it's okay to enjoy yourself be
silly and of course even dance a part of
me really laughs that this episode even
exists I mean Lord avatar does what
loose it's just so strange that you know
the creators of this just had to do it
but dude this is the second episode of
the last season and the last one was
pretty heavy this is the follow-up work
in it I mean yeah okay maybe you need
something light after so much drama but
this is really light and really freakin
corny yeah Betar has had a lot of corny
moments but this is throwing a prom in
the heartland of your enemy I don't know
it's just a little really Footloose
Kevin Bacon they did the Footloose on
top of doing the obvious follow your
dreams message it does give us a nice
chance to see again that not all the
Fire Nation is made up of evil foot
soldiers there are normal people with
normal kids and unlike the ones before
we get a little bit of that gentleness
rather than just see it it's cute it's
innocent but if I told someone this was
my favorite all-time show and this was
the episode they saw they think there
was fucking mental if you like seeing
Avatar do Footloose that fine it's not
like I can't see why it's just Footloose
Bato of the Water Tribe when I first saw
this it was my least favorite episode
why because I felt it won against
everything that Aang was our team comes
across an old friend from the Water
Tribe named Pato
about to recommend them to look for
their father and finds a letter from
exactly him Sokka and Katara's dad
afraid Sokka and Katara's he actually
hides the letter destroying the
possibility of them being reunited I
couldn't believe it when I saw this
episode this is a friggin egg who
destroyed this opportunity for his two
best friends whom he owned with
everything to foreseeing what's left of
their family it just it didn't feel like
him I know he's a kid and kids make
emotional mistakes but they've
established him as being smart and
sensitive he grows up an environment
that is nothing but this with everything
that Aang's characters seemed in what he
was taught this just didn't seem like
him
it seemed downright alien even Sokka and
Katara's seemed a little harsher than
usual but to be fair it's kind of hard
to blame them this was a pretty big deal
now with that said there are a lot of
good elements looking back on again we
got to meet Jun the bounty hunter there
was still some awesome fighting and it
does I guess cement them as a family
unit it's the only time though I've ever
seen this character not feel like the
character which I suppose is good seeing
how lots of shows make that mistake
often and this one only slips up once
some good fighting and still an overall
good message but man I will never get
that choice
and the number one worst episode of oh
you Timmy you know it's the Great Divide
yep the universally hated episode by
practically every avatar fan it doesn't
connect much to the grand story it
doesn't further much character and it's
considered by many to be a complete
waste of time so is it really as bad as
all that well let's take a look at the
set up two feuding tribes find they have
to cross through a canyon called the
Great Divide and aint decides to help
them through it trying constantly to be
the Peacekeeper all the tribe can do is
bicker complain shout yell and blame
each other for everything and I hope
you're a fan of that because that is
literally what takes up the majority of
the episode after listening to oh I
don't know twenty four minutes of this
egg finally lets them know that they're
feuding was all based on a bogus history
that this great big warring few was
actually based on two little kids
fighting over a ball that's actually a
pretty funny idea the tribes decide
there's no reason to hate each other and
that the honor they were fighting for
can be reached if they all decide to
forgive the catch Aang is a fucking liar
you could call it lying what I need the
whole thing off you did not that is so
wrong now where's that custard tart and
good lord remember how we talked about
breaking character in the last one we're
on the peaceful airbending philosophy of
balance and truths as I say just make
shit up if you can't find the best route
just lie about it
no harm done so not only do you have an
episode that's mostly complaining and
arguing even among the main characters
but you also have would have been a
clever message about prejudice reduced
down to if someone's a racist lie your
ass off these we could have had
something if Angus stopped talking and
the two separated but straight up making
up a story explaining years of real hurt
this is a weird message they're trying
to convey I'm not even sure what you're
supposed to take out of it sometimes
lying is good the needs of the
short-term solution outweigh the needs
of the long-term solution
the truth will set you free only when
it's convenient this episode was so
hated that even in the series recap they
act out the scene pretending like it
never happened
look it's the Great Divide the biggest
Canyon in the earth Kingdom let's keep
flying it's clunky it's misguided it's
confused much like the Great Divide it's
a great mess let's keep flying but even
with that said I still don't think it's
a bad episode because I still stand by
that there are no bad episodes even that
it's weak as avatar was fantastic
because no matter what it always had
great characters great story great
animation and the ability to take
children and adult 100% seriously it's a
show unlike any other we've ever seen
yes there's a lot of things that aren't
good and the Great Divide but the
animation is still great
I still like following these characters
I still like hearing their performance
I still want to see where the story is
gonna go that's the incredible hole that
the show has even when it's not great
there's still great things in it and
that's why avatar will always be one of
a kind
I am seeing this is all about keeping
the grand balance it only makes sense
next week to do the top 11 greatest
avatar episodes there will they call me
the fuck down
I don't know critic there's still two
minutes left in the time-barred
something could still go wrong yeah yeah
like there's somebody out there who
could possibly do something bad to you
oh yeah what are people gonna do
complain on message boards right mean
comments show me one person who would
actually be crazy enough to cause me
physical harm because of this list
sir I just received word from the Avatar
fanbase they say the nostalgia critic
has disgraced the franchise by doing a
top 11 worst episodes list how do you
wish to respond tell them I'll be
arriving in one week's time I look
forward to winning back the fanbase yes
sir okay let's go